It was the last Friday of the school year
and I had been actually subbing
for a teacher for three days.
It just seemed like a nice day.
On May 18th, 2018, a gunman entered a high school
in Santa Fe, Texas and opened fire.
I look down and I realize in
my pants I had bloody holes
in my pants and I realized I'm shot.
The gunman killed ten people.
Flo Rice was shot six times.
And then finally, Scot managed
to... he managed to find me.
For four years, Flo and Scot have
told their story over and over
to push for new laws that
could prevent mass shootings.
It’s made them part of a recurring
conversation on guns in the US.
And a cycle the country has
seemed stuck in for decades:
a mass shooting, a push for
reform, and then no action.
"...the tragic school shooting
in Santa Fe, Texas..."
"...this time in El Paso..."
"...nine people killed in Dayton..."
"...how many years do we have to go through this?"
"...Congress is paralyzed..."
"...we collectively seem to ask the same question."
"What does it take to pass some
gun reform in this country?"
But here’s the thing:
this cycle of inaction on gun
laws isn’t exactly accurate.
Over the past few decades, federal
legislation on guns has been rare.
But in state legislatures, mass
shootings have led to new gun laws.
Thousands of them.
...and how those laws have
emerged can tell us a lot
about the future of guns in the US.
In 2020, a study tried to determine “the
impact of mass shootings on gun policy.”
They looked at 25 years of
high profile mass shootings.
Then, they looked at gun
legislation passed during that time.
Over 3,000 laws across all fifty states.
When they took a closer look at
those laws, a pattern emerged
that at first seemed unsurprising.
State legislatures controlled by Democrats
were more likely to pass tighter gun laws.
Republican-controlled states
typically loosened gun laws.
But they found a key difference.
Mass shootings didn't have any
statistically significant effect
on the number of laws passed by Democrats.
While for Republican legislatures
a mass shooting roughly doubles the number of laws
enacted that loosen gun
restrictions in the next year.
To arm more teachers, for
example, or arm more school staff.
That's James Barragan, a politics
reporter at the Texas Tribune.
There is more access to guns afterwards.
A state like Texas would go
more towards pro-gun policies
in the aftermath of a gun shooting.
Texas has some of the loosest
gun laws in the nation.
And that matters — for
people all over the country.
People probably don't know about the importance of
state gun laws and really state laws in general.
Our gun laws at the federal level have been
frozen in time since basically the 1990s,
which allowed the states to have
a much bigger role and a much
bigger influence in how gun culture
played out in their jurisdictions.
Let’s look at Texas.
In 1991, a gunman killed 23 people at
a Luby’s restaurant in Killeen, Texas.
A woman there named Suzanna Hupp lost
both her parents in the shooting.
She believed she could have stopped the massacre
and turned her experience into a
crusade for loosening gun laws.
"I'm mad at my legislators for
legislating me out of the right
to protect myself and my family."
It worked.
In 1994, Texas elected a
new governor: George W Bush
who made it legal to carry a
concealed gun his first year in office
and set off a trend in the state
that's continued for decades.
For example in 2012, after
the Sandy Hook elementary
school shooting drew attention
to gun laws across the country
Texas responded a few months
later by creating a program
allowing some school employees
to carry guns in school.
In 2017, a gunman killed 26 people at
First Baptist Church in Sutherland Springs.
Within two years, Texas made it legal
to carry weapons in places of worship.
But after the Santa Fe High School shooting,
governor Greg Abbott did something unusual.
He asked lawmakers to consider a “red flag law”
which would allow authorities
to take firearms away
from a person courts deemed dangerous.
That is not something that
Republicans in this state often do.
Flo and Scot were also pushing for
legislation in response to Santa Fe
like laws that would hold
parents accountable
if their guns were used by their children
to harm people.
They also pushed to make it
harder to buy ammunition online.
Our shooter, he just checked
the box and said, yes, I'm 18.
And they delivered it to his doorstep.
You can't get alcohol delivered without
showing proof of I.D. or something.
But he ordered ammunition.
Their hope for stricter laws was
in line with Texas public opinion.
Polling showed only a small minority
of Texans supported loosening gun laws
and just over half supported tightening them.
We thought it was common
sense that this would be done.
They came to Flo's hospital
room the week of the shooting.
And we had the governor, lieutenant governor
we had congressmen, we had senators,
their wives, the chief of staff
all in her room at one time, at least 20 people
and said, we're going to take care of you.
We promise we'll be there for you.
We'll fix this.
But in the end, these proposals, along with
Abbot’s openness to red flag laws
went nowhere.
After gun rights supporters went after him.
The gun culture is strong.
But the gun lobby itself also exerts a
lot of pressure on Texas politicians.
There were bills that were put out there,
but they never made it out of committee.
Later in 2019 — two shootings in west Texas
just weeks apart prompted Lieutenant Governor
Dan Patrick to suggest another tighter gun
policy — closing background check loopholes.
That is a very strong comment
from a lieutenant governor who
is very pro-gun and who is
very friendly with the NRA.
But Republican leaders were
saying we may have problems here.
Democrats are pushing to take over the
state house for the first time since 2003.
After elections were over, with
Republicans still in control
in 2021 Texas passed “constitutional carry”:
there would no longer be a requirement
for Texans to have a license
or receive any training
to openly carry handguns.
For me, it's very scary because if I see
someone in public with a gun, I will panic.
That's going to send me into an anxiety attack.
That constitutional carry law that
the state legislature passed in 2021
had been rejected by Republican leaders.
But as the Republican Party has gone further
and further to the right on issues
you get a fringe of the
party that is much more vocal
about all kinds of issues, including gun rights.
In recent years, a better
organized gun control movement
has seen more success with
tightening laws in some states.
But the movement to expand
gun access isn’t stopping.
In 2002 fewer than half of the 50
states had one party in control of
both the state legislature
and the governor’s office.
Today, three quarters of the states do.
That means, in the places where
Republicans or Democrats have full control
they can push through new gun
laws with little chance of a veto.
What happens and you see it
in state house to state house
is one state passes a law that is very
successful for one side of the aisle.
And then another state house
adopts a very, very similar law.
Remember that constitutional carry law in Texas?
Today, 24 states have similar
laws on the books for that, too.
And more than 400 local governments across
20 states have adopted variations on
a “second amendment sanctuary law”
meaning a city, town, or
county refuses to recognize
any state or federal gun laws
that they believe violate the Second Amendment.
These things get replicated. They get
cloned, they go from state to state
and they essentially make up this
patchwork of laws throughout the country.
In June 2022, in the aftermath
of the Uvalde shooting in Texas
President Biden signed the most
significant federal gun bill in 30 years.
One thing it does is incentivize
states to pass red flag laws.
But it can’t make them do it.
That power still belongs to the states.
I have survivor's guilt because I'm alive.
And so I feel like I have to keep
speaking out. I have to do what I can.
There's times when I just think I'm going to stop.
I cannot do this for my own mental health.
But we just keep, we keep going.